- [Interviewer] All right, Tanya.
Tanya, where are you from?
Where'd you grow up?
- [Tanya] L.A.
- [Interviewer] South central?
- [Tanya] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your your family,
you had both your parents growing up?
- [Tanya] Not really.
Dad when I was, my
father hasn't really been
in my life since, about six.
My mom died when I was very young.
- [Interviewer] Your mom died?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry.
Where was dad?
Just out of the picture?
- Yeah, he was battling addiction.
- [Interviewer] Oh I see.
- So.
- [Interviewer] And who raised you then?
- The village.
- [Interviewer] So did you
go to the foster system or?
- No.
- [Interviewer] When you say the village?
- Everybody, it takes a
village to raise a child.
The neighbors, people you know,
people you meet in your life.
- [Interviewer] So not even family,
just neighbors and friends?
- Couple of family.
Like an aunt or two.
- [Interviewer] Were you bounced around?
- Yeah, I was all over.
Young, hurt, parents gone.
Super young.
- [Interviewer] What kind of
kid were you in high school?
- Good kid.
Cheerleader.
The ROTC.
- [Interviewer] Was there any abuse
when you were growing up?
- No.
- [Interviewer] No?
Then you went out on your own at what age?
- 13.
- [Interviewer] You went to the street?
When you worked Figueroa?
When did you start working the street?
- Right after like my mom passed.
Like, I was lost.
Plus, you know my aunt
did the best she could do.
People, you know.
But I was always raised like, you know,
you got to get your own.
I see examples in front of me.
You know, nobody wants to
take care of nobody else.
Especially if it's not their own, so.
I had to live, I had to eat, you know.
- [Interviewer] What age did you start
working as a prostitute?
- About 14.
- [Interviewer] 14?
You worked on your own or with the pimp?
- I've had people to look out
for me, but mainly on my own.
Cause I was just one of those.
No, I don't understand
giving you all my money.
No, no.
I'm trying to live and take
care of me and find my way.
I'm not giving you my money.
For what?
For you just to watch me?
I can watch myself.
I'm doing the work.
I'm going to keep it for myself.
- [Interviewer] Have you
been arrested for this?
- Mm hmm.
- [Interviewer] How many times?
- 10, 15?
- [Interviewer] Wow.
Did you ever had any bad experiences
with the guys that pick you up?
- Um, yeah. Rob.
Picked up and dropped off
somewhere way out the district.
By the grace of God,
I've never been seriously injured
or raped or nothing like that,
but I know a lot of people who have.
And it's a scary world, scary life.
I wouldn't recommend
anybody to go that way.
- [Interviewer] So do you have any family
to stay in contact with now?
- Some.
I do. But...
I really distanced myself
from a lot of people.
My mom died.
It did a lot to me. Caused
a lot emotional pain.
Because I was a child
and I didn't understand.
So, you know, I just did my own thing.
Did my own thing.
- [Interviewer] Are drugs a
part of the picture for you?
- I have tampered with, you know,
a little bit here, a little bit there.
But drinking, mainly.
- [Interviewer] Drinking mostly?
Does this lifestyle
get you down sometimes?
- Of course it would.
It's like, you're selling your
body on the street to man.
Not because sometimes you want to do it.
Cause like, well I know
I can get the money
for this for that.
So that's what I'm gonna
do, but is it right?
Should you be? No.
You shouldn't.
And it's definitely, I should
have had somebody older
to guide me and support
me in the direction,
instead of letting me be freewill.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. You'd
like that guidance as a kid.
- Oh yeah.
- [Interviewer] Did you have
friends doing the same thing?
- [Tanya] Maybe one or
two, but not really.
They all still was kids at home
with their parents getting
punishments and all that shit.
Sneaking out, running away.
I never had a chance to like sneak out
or run away get caught before
the street lights came on.
Like (beep), oh my God,
it's just past curfew.
Damn, I stayed out at the party too long.
I never. I did what I wanted to.
- [Interviewer] You can stay up all night.
- [Tanya] I did what I wanted to.
I clubbed.
I did everything.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have kids of your own?
- [Tanya] I have a son.
- [Interviewer] Are you raising him?
- [Tanya] Not at this second.
I was.
But, things happen in life.
There's some things
just out of our control.
Not saying I'm a bad parent.
Just life gets hard.
Sometimes you may get a
curve ball thrown at you.
- [Interviewer] Who's raising him now?
- [Tanya] Family.
- [Interviewer] What was
the best time of your life?
- [Tanya] I have a lot of best times.
You know, childhood before
my mom passed was great.
My son.
Great.
Understanding that
everything isn't your fault,
put a smile on my face.
That you don't have to feel
embarrassed or shameful
for what you're going through,
what you had to go through.
Because I mean, life ain't easy,
but I made it matter.
I'm trying to make it better.
That's what I know.
As long as you're trying
to work towards better
that's what counts.
But it's not going to be easy.
You're going to go through a lot.
Like they say, you gotta go through a lot
of pain and hurt to get to the happy days.
I mean, I can't cry over spilled milk.
- [Interviewer] What was
the worst time of your life?
- Being on the streets.
Sleepy. Tired.
My mom dying.
- [Interviewer] Your mom dying.
- Losing my son.
- [Interviewer] Have
you been in love before?
- Yes.
I have.
- [Interviewer] Is it
the father of your child?
- No.
Childhood love.
Still know him.
Still in love with him.
I first met him when I was a kid.
Brings me joy, happiness.
It's not easy, but...
- [Interviewer] How old are you now?
- A little old.
- [Interviewer] You don't look old.
- I'm a little old.
I'm in my thirties.
- [Interviewer] How do you
think this life has changed you?
- Help me understand more.
It helped me want more.
It opened my eyes.
I'm kinda glad I experienced it.
I've been through it, going through it.
'Cause, I don't know.
Sometimes you need to go to struggle
and to see what you really got out there.
I mean, some people
may say I sound stupid,
but everybody wasn't handed a spoon,
and got money and family
do this and do that.
My life was hard.
It still is hard.
But, knowing now that
it's a different way out.
I knew it was a different
way out as a kid,
but I didn't know.
'Cause I was a kid.
But, I don't regret it though.
Do I regret being prostitute?
No, I don't.
Do I regret anything I've done?
Maybe a few things, but no, not really.
Because it's going to make me to be
a strong individual that I am.
- [Interviewer] Did you have
dreams of a different life
when you were a young girl?
What'd you want to do?
- Be a housewife with a job,
and be a mother.
But, I wanted to be a
cook and a beautician.
That's me doing hair and cooking.
And have two, maybe three kids.
And a husband.
Be there at home, cooking, cleaning,
taking care of the kids.
Make sure my husband got what he need.
He satisfied.
He's not wanting for nothing.
But still, I'm going to
get up and go to work.
Cause I need to make my money,
match his.
- [Interviewer] They can all still happen.
You're still young.
What's the worst thing
that's happened to you
in this lifestyle?
- Losing my son.
- [Interviewer] Losing your son?
Is it because you're working
the street that, that happened?
- Yup.
I mean, I refuse to go,
or hear my son ever say
he don't have.
I can't do for him.
'Cause I can do anything.
I don't care what it'll take.
I'll do anything to make
sure my son is not without.
Ever.
I don't care what nobody says.
Nobody, and I do have a lot
of pride with asking people
for handouts and this.
I'm gonna get it on my own.
That's my child.
That's mine, he belongs to me.
So therefore, it's my responsibility.
Because I can ask somebody for something,
but well, they have a choice.
I don't, because he's mine.
So I'll do whatever it takes.
And if I have to do it today again
for my child, I'll do whatever.
Yes.
- [Interviewer] All right time.
Thank you so much for sharing your story.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.